going up against mike miner
who's pitching on seven days rest
and coming off a quality start at
houston in a game that the royals
eventually lost that's right mike miner
wants for him to do good things tonight
now the 2-2 delivery
going the other way and it's very laid
off single for mile straw the table
setters and he realizes i think now
being around long enough that my job is
to get on base and let these guys do
their work
fly ball very shallow center and whit
will take care of it
one down
and that's a strike over the inside edge
there it is a change up how about that
beauty
straw runs and that is a strikeout on a
high fastball so mike miner strikes out
two and works around the lead-off single
well tristan mckenzie is going to be our
indian starting pitcher brought to you
by your northeast ohio ford dealers
mackenzie on the year three and five two
of those wins have come on the road and
one of them right here in kansas city
back on may 6th
that's maybe playable you chang over
into foul ground
and he hangs on
a little line drive jam shot to short
where ned has to hurry and they just do
retire lopez for round number two
boy he had no time he had to get up and
just get rid of it in a hurry
the pitch
very wow nice pitch that was nasty
and that ends the first inning no score
in kansas city
hunter dozier with a runner at second
and two down
dozier hits it to the gap in right
center field and down
one-nothing
royals as dozier
gets an rbi with two outs
yeah there you go
here is the lefty dealing and levarnway
swings and misses at the high fastball
and strikes out
that's his third strikeout that fastball
up he's got a good spin rate on that it
looks good
swing and a miss
two down
back to back strikeouts
and mike miner first time through
only allowed one base runner and struck
out four the o2
swinging a miss chased the breaking ball
in the dirt tagged out by lavarnway
so that's the third strikeout
now the one-two
flew it by four strikeouts for mckenzie
he has retired four straight
rivera makes a sliding play and throws a
strike to dozier
nice baseball awareness
for rivera over their third base vance
wilson the infield instructor for the
royals is telling me before the game
yesterday that
he just knows where to play he knows he
has a good feel of the game
sharply hit nikki lopez back hands he
plants his feet on the outfield grass
and throws out ramirez
vicky happened to be there with good
soft hands good throw good timing
here's owen miller great opportunity
here in a spot where he's really
struggled in this his first major league
season
hammered deep left field down the line
and it is long gone
a three-run homer for owen miller and
the indians take the lead
fourth homer of the year for owen and
just his fourth hit of the season with
runners in scoring position but boy oh
boy was that a big one now the two-two
we're gonna miss that a nasty breaking
ball
that's six strikeouts for
stixx mckenzie
i mean they started him off slider put
him away curveball
rivera cuts it off spins throws
on target
heck of a play showing some good range
to the left on a good speedy runner
spins and relies on the arm fires it
counting by step nick witgren
on the pitch
49th appearance of the year whitcrin
will have the
five six in seven hitters due up for kc
and the payoff pitch
hearted ground ball but right at the
second baseman owen miller
one down
hard hit ground ball right at jose
ramirez
[Applause]
and there are two down
olivares hits it hard into the corner
and up against the wall
and now ramirez
had some difficulty just picking the
ball up
but olivares
is on with a two-out double
oh yeah painted the outside corners
three straight heaters
nick whittgren with a scoreless seventh
the pitch to you chang
how about you chang with the base
hitting the right field coming around
third jose ramirez will score and you
chang delivers once again his second hit
of the night through the right side of
the infield this gives him his 26th run
batted in on the year it's 4-1 cleveland
shaw brings the hands up right by his
chin and fires wave down fastball
elevated and he makes quick work of
emmanuel rivera
there's a line drive base hit center
field so with merrifield after fouling
off a couple on the first base side got
a pitch
to his liking and drills it into center
runner going
and how about that ahmed rosario just
stayed on the back got the ground ball
right to him i hit first base and
running sprinting off the field that was
outstanding
well he slowed that one down and santana
hammered it
i think that was a slider that was up in
the strike zone and carlos jumped all
over it
[Applause]
his second hit in the series clausee
with a one-two delivery swung on rip to
first diving stop by chang gets up dives
to first down in time that will get
challenged it is gonna be bang bang
either way he's out oh yes and so
they're taking their time and he's out
at first base yeah give chang credit boy
he did everything in his power clase
sets here's the 1-1 delivery
by ball center field mile straw is there
it 11 in a row the indians have won
against the kansas city royals as they
sweep this three-game series